after 16 days of shutdown the house of
representatives finally approved the
bipartisan budget bill
the deal ends the specter of a u.s debt
default earlier president obama welcomed
senate approval of the compromise i want
to thank the leaders of both parties for
getting us to this point
once this agreement
arrives on my desk i will sign it
immediately
we'll begin reopening
our government immediately
the senate voted overwhelmingly in favor
the deal was a work of senior senators
from both the democratic and republican
sides
it allows the treasury to borrow until
the beginning of february
18 days senate leaders on both sides of
the aisle praised the agreement the
compromise we reached will provide our
economy with the stability it
desperately needs our country came to
the brink of disaster and republicans
remain determined
to repeal
this terrible law
but for today
for today
the relief we hope for is to reopen the
government republicans in the house of
representatives emerged as today's
losers
their leader speaker john boehner gave
no interviews but said his party had
fought the good fight and lost